all right this is pretty exciting
we're going to look at order out of
chaos we're not just going to pick
numbers out of the air i've actually
organized something here for us i've got
some uno playing cards okay i've got
nine
and they're all different which is
important so first of all what i'm going
to do is i'm going to give it a very
light shuffle
let's put it out here so we've got nine
six four five one
seven two
three and eight okay so let's look at
these so this is these are nine cards in
a particular order particular
permutation let's see if we can find
four cards that are in ascending order
so
ascending order so we can see we've got
a four here
um
we've got a five
we've got a seven
and we've got an eight
okay so they didn't need to be right
next to one another but we found four
five seven eight okay how about
four cards in descending order all right
so nine is a good start because
that's as high as you can get so we've
got nine
six
five
and one
or we could have had two
or we could have had three so
look at this here
now brady
let's look at this
we've got nine cards so that means that
we have nine
factorial different ways to organize
them
which is
362
880 permutations but
there is
1000
ways that you can organize these nine
cards such that there are no
four
numbers
uh in
ascending order
or
descending order and i know you want
what you're thinking
why is that a square number
yeah
i wasn't but i am now
because it is it's
42 squared
and the reason why is because it
actually follows this marvelous little
formula here 9 factorial
on 1 to the 1 by 2 to the 2 by 3 to the
3 by 4 to the 2 by 5 to the 1 all
squared so the point is this is some
serious maths so 1 764 divided by
36280 is approximately equal to 0.5
so at
chance
if you just take it at random
there's a 0.5 percent chance that you
can actually put this in an order
so that there's no for increasing or
decreasing okay
so brady
would you like to make some money
i'm willing to put down
20 pounds
okay
20 pounds against a probability of 0.5
at random but i think you're pretty
smart
so if you're able to organize this in a
way
that there's no for increasing or
decreasing that's yours
gosh
well how long have i got it
oh you got as long as you like
okay my 20 pounds is looking safe
do you want to have another guy no no
it'll be a smaller denomination all
right here we go
here we go a little bit of that's the
only time i'm interested in gambling i'm
actually just testing you
okay so this is it this is the way we do
it what you do is you split it up
into groups of three
and you go like this
you're gonna
so looking at it from left to right what
i've done
is that you can see it goes three two
one
six five four
nine eight seven so the maximum
of descending
is three three three
and then if you wanna go for ascending
all right
what you do is you basically you can
only take one from each of these groups
so it doesn't matter which one so you
could go like two
five
eight for example or you could pick any
one so you could go one
four
seven right
but
if we add one more card
okay
the beautiful zero
all bets are off
literally
and i'll tell you why is because if you
have 10 cards what happens is if i put
my 0 here wherever i put it
i'm always going to create
4 ascending or 4 descending right so if
i put my 0 here you can see it goes 0 1
4 7 in that particular permutation
if i put it here it doesn't change if i
put it here it doesn't change
okay if i put it here
all right i no longer can do that here
but now
look what i've got three two one zero
and that doesn't change if i put it here
here here here or here
okay
now
that
is not only just for that particular
permutation
it so happens that four
ten factorial permutations
which is
three
six two eight
eight zero zero there are now zero ways
to find no four numbers ascending or
descending order
no
right which is a strong result which
means we've got order out of chaos why
should that be the case
there's a second video in which simon
explains all the mathematics behind
what's going on in this video if you'd
like to see it there'll be a link in the
description and on the screen it's about
eight or nine minutes long so i thought
i'd do it separately and keep this video
a bit shorter if you'd like to see my
really embarrassing attempt at arranging
the cards which cost me 20 pounds
i will make that available but there's
going to be a bit of a catch have a look
in the video description and i'll
explain how you can see it